why does Sean have a cooking show isn't
even not a cook - shot have a food show
that's not a cook Sean doesn't not a
cook yeah well how come I'm teaching you
so many things
huh hey what's going on everybody this
is Sean Evans coming at you from an LED
screen surrounded by 50 episodes worth
of Sean in the wild history that's right
Sean in the wild has gone on now for 50
episodes and how are we gonna celebrate
with a clip show of course our producers
have pulled some of the greatest kitchen
hacks some of the greatest cooking
lessons some of the greatest life
lessons ever to come out of Sean in the
wild you know what we're gonna do roll
the tape so when we put the cheese on
[Music]
the whole reason there you go I get this
dish is basically look at this one scene
right here take a look at that up top
get yours on the four chefs and then
just BAM let's get that let's get that a
little bit of a fail here's what I'm
gonna say it might not look like I
wanted it to look but this is gonna
taste amazing
[Music]
there's certain things that I learned
that were like mistakes that a lot of
people take wasabi and mix it in with
the soy sauce technically not supposed
to do that I'm not gonna like nitpick
every little thing they do because I
feel like that's an [ __ ] move right
well when you're gonna save them from
ruining their meal then I'll then I'll
chime in and then chef I notice you know
we're going with our fingers on this
when is it when do you use chopsticks
when do you just go fingers doesn't mean
I have no rules about that
I mean like a you know people not used
to that's the picking up the arrow fish
with your own hands and go ahead use the
chopsticks can you kind of speak to the
beautifully pink aspect of the steak
because we have one of the most active
and engaged raw meat taskforces in the
history of youtube that seems you know
every time our audience sees a little
bit of pink they freaked out
what are you lose by overcooking it
you're gonna lose flavor you're gonna
lose moisture and you know it's be quite
honest it's like this steak was aged for
60 days if we were to cook this well
done it's like it's losing all of that
time all of that you know those
beautiful flavors it's just gonna
dissipate there's no point
so usually what you do with these guys
is obvious this is way to this you have
a straw with these guys what you do is
usually just take it put it in your
spoon kind of like poke like a little
hole on the side or something and then
you can oh man oh boy
huh then not just happen oh boy I see I
just smell the soup that's not that's
not what I'm gonna do it that's not how
you do what you do is you would just
kind of kind of sit like with your mouth
[Music]
there you go Yeah right just like that
you're doing better than me uh huh huh
let's get that out get that out and then
you can eat it but first of all choked
up on your back come here and then curl
your fingers around proper and then
you're going to slice down and away from
your body down and away from your body
don't be afraid of the board down in a
way don't saw how am i doing not
terrible so hold this together
always keep your fingers curled under
when you're using a knife on this hand
right and that's called up right and you
move the knife along the cutting board
and you keep moving your fingers back so
one more left and it's the headliner
it's the much-talked-about
much-discussed the chicken feet
situation you never had this before
first time now the texture is a lot of
times something that people have a tough
time getting over basically the rule is
if you break down whatever you can't
shoot don't get that everything I'll eat
it I mean it gets ugly
so a lot of people say just put in and I
was holding their mouth and just like
try to figure it out just figure out
with their tongue but if you want to be
more simple I just eat the outside a
little bit and don't don't be afraid to
use your hands too
nice good job man I am impressed
good deboning skills there's nothing
that turns me off about the flavor hmm
it's just the mental hurdles that you
have to jump in your head the mark
against it though is it's so difficult
you know there's like 30 different bone
shards in my mouth but I would recommend
it I would order it again
chicken feet no big deal all right
here's some of the basic rules when you
eat at a Filipino house you ready and
one we don't give a [ __ ] if you've eaten
already
and we don't care if you're a fool
you're about to get more whole second
rule you ready for this
there's no nice we don't cut your spoon
and your fork are your utensils spoon
goes on the right hand before it goes in
the left hand hold the meat down with
your fork and then cool with your spoon
and that's how you cut you don't need
nights we use those for weapons we also
have one more rule if you don't have
utensils you just wash your hands so it
goes down on the plate and then you
blast the rice like you like you're
grabbing a teddy bear like that they
come up and then win the prize Wiener
Wiener Wiener Filipino dinner I'm gonna
hit you with a question quick because I
know that timing on the smash burgers is
crucial
you hit it right away right over anyone
how does the burger keep its juiciness
when you're smashing down on it so thin
well it's cooking so quickly it doesn't
have a chance to expel too much moisture
and we're gonna flip them as soon as you
start seeing you see there's like brown
dark brown stuff forming here yeah we
really added it's been on here for what
and then it now and it's just about
ready to flip so you want to really get
underneath there go fast what are you
looking for in this crust to know that
it's ready to go I'm looking for hmm a
really deep brown crust and knowing when
to flip you'll start to see the brown
around the edges and see it through the
holes in the padding
and just like any great diner burgers
we're only going to put the cheese on
one patty for each burger what kind of
cheese are you using if you want a
classic diner style burger especially a
smash burger you're going American
cheese yeah look at that you don't want
to salt it you just want to leave it
like that add a little bit of butter and
then this is where you start mixing it
no again cold pan this is like the
bamboozlement of it all because people
think you add cheese to it or like cream
but it's really just keeping the the
butter cold it emulsify it in the in the
eggs so when you get it to like this
point where it's like some white we'll
go ahead and throw it on the heat and
you notice I haven't seasoned it at all
and the butter hasn't broken from the
eggs yet so it's not like oily the trick
to making really good eggs besides slow
and slow and spinning it all the time is
if it looks like it's a little
undercooked in the pan it's already done
Ivan can you give me the plan of attack
can you give me robbing his own each one
what are the two rules only two rule
rule number one eat it while it's hot
and then I see people taking it out and
happy the ball Robin yeah and then you
want to slurp it you get all the broth
and all the flavor kind of whipping up
into your mouth and it's a great way to
take a little bit less than you're
thinking so while you practice your
Slurpee and then you want to slurp it up
like you drink really hot coffee in the
morning you know you need that first sip
when it's burning hot drink exactly okay
[Music]
nailed it nailed it you know my first
time
why does Sean have a Food Show he
doesn't even know how to cook well there
you have it it's the life lessons
it's the trips in the kitchen it's the
cooking adventures it's the characters
it's everyone and you know who else it
is it's you the fans I just want to
thank you 50 episodes so am
you do not want to miss us next week we
are doing our season finale with someone
that you guys know and someone that you
love I wish I could tell you but I can't
my lips are sealed
you'll have to tune in next week thank
you very much roll credits
[Music]